J'aimerais vous faire part d'un projet
que j'ai entrepris il y a environ 16 ans :
créer de nouvelles formes de vie.
Je les fabrique avec ces tubes
qu'on appelle «tubes électriques» en Hollande.
Nous allons présenter un film
qui explique un peu l'histoire du projet.
Narratrice : Un jour, ces bêtes vivront en troupeau sur les plages.
Theo Jansen travaille dur pour que cette évolution se réalise.
Theo Jansen : Je veux laisser aller ces créatures sur les plages.
Elles devraient y survivre
toutes seules, et dans l'avenir,
apprendre à vivre de façon autonome.
Dans quelques années, elles marcheront toutes seules.
Narratrice : Les bêtes mécaniques puiseront leur énergie non pas dans la nourriture, mais dans le vent.
Le vent remue leurs plumes dorsales, ce qui actionne leurs pattes.
Les bêtes se déplacent latéralement sur le sable mouillé,
avec leur museau face au vent.
Dès qu'elles s'avancent dans les vagues déferlantes ou dans le sable sec, elles s'arrêtent,
puis repartent dans la direction opposée.
L'évolution a produit de nombreuses espèces.
Voici Animaris Currens Ventosa.
(Applaudissements)
Jansen : C'est un troupeau dont les membres sont conçus selon un code génétique.
C'est une race dont tous les membres sont différents.
Le code gagnant se reproduira.
On voit ici un mouvement de vague allant de gauche à droite.
Oui, c'est bien de gauche à droite.
Voici une nouvelle génération, une nouvelle famille,
capable de stocker le vent.
Les ailes pompent de l'air dans des bouteilles de limonade,
situées sur le dessus,
desquelles la bête puise son énergie au cas où le vent se calme
et la marée monte. Elles ont ainsi assez d'énergie
pour atteindre les dunes et sauver leur vie, car elles se noient facilement.
(Rires)
Je vais vous montrer cet animal.
(Applaudissements) Merci.
Les rapports entre les tubes sont très importants pour la marche.
Il y a 11 nombres que j'appelle les 11 nombres sacrés.
Ils correspondent à la longueur des tubes permettant ce type de démarche.
En fait, c'est la roue réinventée.
Ça fonctionne comme une roue.
L'axe d'une roue demeure à un niveau constant.
Cette hanche reste aussi toujours au même niveau.
En fait, c'est mieux que la roue :
essayez de faire du vélo sur la plage,
et vous verrez comme c'est difficile.
Ces pattes marchent sur le sable,
tandis que la roue reste en contact permanent avec le sol.
Donc, 5000 ans après l'invention de la roue,
on a une nouvelle roue ! Dans le prochain clip...
-- pouvez-vous le montrer s'il vous plaît ? --
...on voit que de lourdes charges peuvent être déplacées.
Un homme pousse à l'arrière,
mais ça pourrait fonctionner au vent.
Ça pèse 3,2 tonnes.
Ici, elle utilise le vent stocké dans les bouteilles.
Elle est munie d'un senseur à obstacles, et peut changer de direction.
On voit ici qu'elle change de direction.
Pourrait-on m'apporter l'antenne ?
OK. Bien.
Elles doivent survivre aux périls de la plage,
dont la mer. Ceci représente la mer.
Elles doivent donc être sensibles à l'eau.
Voici l'antenne hydrosensible.
Ce tube est très important. Il aspire l'air,
et il sent une résistance lorsque de l'eau y pénètre.
Si l'animal marche vers la mer,
aussitôt qu'il touche l'eau... on devrait entendre l'air...
Oui ! S'il ne sent rien, il se noiera.
Nous avons ici le cerveau de l'animal.
En réalité, c'est un compteur de pas,
un compteur binaire.
Aussitôt qu'il entre dans la mer,
il se produit un changement dans les zéros et les uns.
Il sait toujours où il est sur la plage. C'est un cerveau très simple.
Il se dit : « Il y a la mer, les dunes, et je suis ici. »
C'est la pensée simple de ces animaux de plage.
Merci.
Un de leurs principaux ennemis est la tempête.
Voici une partie du museau de Animaris Percipiere.
Quand le museau est fixé au sol, tout l'animal l'est aussi.
Lorsqu'arrive une tempête,
l'animal enfonce un pieu dans le sol. (Rires)
Le museau est fixé, alors tout l'animal l'est aussi.
Quand le vent tourne, le museau de l'animal tourne toujours face au vent.
Dans quelques années, ces animaux survivront seuls,
mais je dois encore beaucoup les aider.
Mesdames et messieurs, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements).